they make it their business to mind your
business surprise New York City Council
members have actually ended a ban the
one on brunching outside before noon and
bud and ski Bloomberg well he's actually
okay with the move but don't let that
morsel get your hopes up some school
cafeteria workers dared to place orders
for butter and now Medlen Mike's
henchmen are putting the heat on them
and this mon stan is none other than the
soon to be termed out mayor was cracking
down and his two most hated things guns
and smokes and he's doing it at the same
time i got a lot of one thing at waves
bloomies thugs busted trinket store
owner Fred Shay's for selling three-inch
lighters shaped like guns the little
doodads may seem harmless but unless
they're bright green red or neon it's
illegal to sell toy guns in bloomies new
york shea said he didn't know they were
illegal but he's getting socked with 60
grand and finds any way they could put
him out of business but the city thinks
it's worth it because this might be
confused with a real gun here's hoping
whoever replaces bloomberg brings some
seriousness back to the mayor's office
look I made some big mistakes and I know
I let a lot of people down followed man
at the month on Twitter submitting your
nanny nominees and click here to watch
another episode